indeed despite the hiccup at the end he
still had a fantastic day time for best
score of the day
welcome to the show you had a poor first
half with the rapid that certainly
wasn't what you wanted but you right at
the ship in the blitz a little couple of
hiccups how do you feel about your
performance so far yeah i'm very happy
about today i think today i scored six
boys so that's equal to
the previous three days combined so
yeah relatively speaking i should be
happy with my performance today but uh i
feel like i could have done a little bit
better especially the last game against
icaru
but in general i think i play much
better today and
at least i think i avoid the last place
now so that's my goal for for today
you
you are a great blitz player you won the
world blitz title what's the difference
between blitz and rapid you think that
makes it such a big differential yeah in
in place it's a lot about
playing fast and trying to avoid
blenders you don't have to play preland
chess you just have to play
decent chess and avoid blenders and try
to be a little bit faster than your
opponents so
i mean it takes a lot more practice to
be good at rapid and classical than in
bliss i would say because simply it's
more like your natural ability you just
push the pieces and see how they go
have you always been good at blitz is
something that you did as a child or
that you practiced when you were younger
yeah i think when i was younger i play a
lot more bliss than recently
so i want to world blitz championship in
2013 and since then i didn't play too
much please but apparently i still
remember how to play you still got it
well we hope to see you do well tomorrow
as well close out the event
congratulations thank you
i can't help but ask this final
round game
that you played with hicaro you made a
decision that frankly alejandro and i
thought was extraordinary you decided to
castle kingside right here and we
thought absolutely for certain your
moves a7 a6 and queen e7 that you were
preparing to put your king on the queen
side
how did you come up with this decision
castle's short
yeah to be honest when i played a6 i
didn't plan where my king would go but i
thought a6 was important to prevent
something coming to b5 like maybe the
bishop coming to b5 ah after a3 bishop
b6 maybe bishop maybe knight b5 all
right so i wanted to control that square
and then when it was time to castle i
mean that that's also one thing in place
you shouldn't plan too far ahead because
you don't have that much time so you
just kind of take it
step by step and here when it was time
to castle i decided to cast a shot
because
honestly the king feels
safer on
on the king side because if i cut so
long then b4 b5 or like a4 something
coming to a6 c5 that concerns you the
problem that we had with castles and
hikaru did not play it hikaru actually
played rook on a1 to e1
we were thinking that the king
you you were ready for uh rook a1 the g1
liam yeah i consider that move
definitely and i thought that was the
best move
uh i thought i have to go knight g3 to
stop him from playing g3 i see and then
probably knight takes a bishop takes i
don't know
right and somehow you were
planning to keep the king's side closed
yeah i think it's still not so easy for
him to open up the king side fair enough
thank you so very much and again our
congratulations really you regaled us
with your great quality of blitz good
luck tomorrow thank you yes sir